[Music]
in today's eight on your side the summer
travel season is about to take off New
York Magazine named jet set Sarah as one
of the best travel Instagrams to follow
we talked to her about how you can save
money and booking time
everyone's getting back out there and
things are going to be busy and they're
going to be expensive jet sets Sarah
says Nationwide we saw the busiest
spring break travel since 2019. planning
Starts Now for summer if you're road
tripping save wear and tear on your own
car by using a rental the good news
there are more rentals available now
than in years past she adds AARP members
can save up to 30 percent on car rentals
with Avis as for trenchesing and summer
lodging we're seeing high demand for
hotels
rates are trending even higher and
vacation rentals are becoming even more
popular this year this year skip gen
travel and multi-gen vacations are all
the rage family members making up for
when they didn't see one another during
and coming out of the pandemic pick a
non-stop flight so everyone's refreshed
she adds when they arrive and consider
all ages at the destination you want to
make sure that you pick a hotel for
example that really has something for
everyone so maybe they've got Spa
they've got golf they've got a great
kids program and that kids program is
comprehensive the booking window for
best prices for domestic travel 28 to 35
days in advance and up to six months for
international flights
if you are traveling internationally and
want to cut down on your wait time at
Customs Etc Jet Set Sarah says most
people are right-handed and therefore
choose a right lane so go left and she
says you'll find the left lane of any
room is often shorter